[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Scott is
on the line in Indianapolis Scott how
can we help George Ken thanks for taking
the call I I'm intimidated by you guys
and uh but I don't have a word question
so I guess I I flk the past I'll figure
out something no I tell you what I'm
gonna think of something while George
answers your Finance question I'm GNA
come up with something to give
away all right guys um so I really have
kind of two two issues going on side by
side uh I have a wife I'm trying to come
up with something to to help her join me
on on managing her budget right now
she's kind of refusing to get involved
and along those same lines we have a uh
a large purchase we're considering it's
it's expensive and time critical and
really be a good time to get on the same
page and we're not really who wants to
make this
purchase we both do okay what is the
purchase can you tell us uh I mean it's
I'm I'm 56 she's 40
and we want another kid we want to
purchase a
kid help doing it whoa whoa whoa and and
the time wait wait wait are you joking
when you say purchase a kid no U I'm
using IVF oh okay I mean I had to ask it
threw me off I was okay so where are you
guys at financially today as it stands
do you have any debt and what's your
income um the only debt we have uh we're
we're davish so we do things difference
uh no mortgage no payments the only uh
we've been married for 2 years uh I
brought in the debt of about 18,000
that's down from 100,000 and that was U
medical bills from my previous wies okay
so you still have the medical bills yes
anything else no okay and what's the
household
income um combined we make about the
same we're doing about 9,000 a month
awesome okay that's a that's a great
shovel so we can clean up this medical
debt quickly do you have an emergency
fund yes okay so you're right on the
davish part and you're trying to get her
on board what is the current hesitation
on her
part well um just a little background
she came she was raised poor family uh
her previous marriage was he was a overs
spender and she had to manage the books
uh I managed the books and in in my
marriage uh so I thought it'd be kind of
a great combination coming together I
made the mistake of saying well since
you've never had money I'll let you keep
your income in a separate account oh boy
and yeah and so you guys currently don't
have combined bank accounts right and
it's because of two previous marriages
there was Financial trauma that happened
in in various ways it sounds like right
so there's a very kind of scarcity
mentality from her upbringing plus the
financial abuse that she experienced in
her previous marriage so she's coming to
the table with a lot of financial
baggage that we have to get to the root
of
and do you feel like you're triggering a
lot of this when you're you're talking
hey I'm going to manage this here's what
we're going to do we're going to get on
the budget and she's starting to get a
little skittish about the whole
thing yeah it's probably at that point
where I'm you know aggressively trying
to get her involved and you know it's
probably it's pushing her away I think
well what is her her longing does she is
she wanting a child is that what's the
real why behind why she why should she
get on this budget what's in it for
her um
see yeah that's yeah that's what I've
been trying to actually use is you know
we've we've got this we we don't really
have the money for it but if you know we
work together on this you know and i'
I've thrown out a couple offers as far
as you know if she gets paid for her
summer work or I get uh you know end of
year bonus I you know we can go ahead
and use that money for it the chance of
success is only
25% so obviously I'm a little reluctant
with those odds to even go into this
Advent uh venture
yeah I'm willing to you know is she all
right let's talk about the relationship
part so obviously you're not on the same
page and I'm guessing that you've said
to her multiple times I want us to
combine income uh combine bank accounts
and all this and work together has she
just said full stop no way I'm not
interested yes so it's non-negotiable to
this point she said no no
thanks yes all right how bad does she
want a child at
badly and you've told her we don't have
the money to afford it what does she say
to
that um I you know I think she's willing
to go into debt for that and that's
where I've kind of said you know we need
to see a couple things first before we
do that okay and how'd that go
over um you know I think she's just
driven to you know she she wants to to
try for another
child let me read between the lines so
you she said no you said we need to buy
our incomes finances all this she said
nope uh then she said I want a baby and
you said okay but we don't have the
money so we need to do this this and
this and her reply was I don't care I
want the baby am I I'm not trying to
make you uncomfortable but this is
important is that what I'm hearing she's
like thanks but no thanks we're doing
it yes my friend this is like you guys
are misaligned on core Financial values
well this is going to wreck your Rel
relationship I want you to fast forward
for 30 seconds you go ahead and give in
cuz she's dug a she's she's dug in and
so we either come to a a compromise of
what we both want she wants the baby you
want to pay cash for it we compromise on
that or we don't move forward on this
that's my position and it ought to be
your position because if you give in and
this isn't a about right or wrong but if
you you and it doesn't work which
there's a 75% chance it doesn't work I'm
hoping for the best my wife and I went
through it it did not work for us so I'm
speaking from a place of of intimate
knowledge of the situation we paid
cash uh you will resent her
tremendously and and and I also got news
for you she'll probably want to try
again now you think about that
future because I think this is a
difficult conversation and probably with
a marriage counselor or a pastor that's
what I think this
is yeah I've listened to the show enough
where I that's that's probably what I
was thinking the advice was going to be
well this is just such an emotionally
charged conversation because we're not
just talking about a frivolous purchase
of a pool okay this is our family we're
talking about so Scott hang on the line
I'm going to do my best effort to get
you guys on the same page by gifting you
one-year Financial Peace University have
her watch all the lessons just have say
hey all I'm asking is that you sit down
and watch these lessons with me and I'm
also going to give you every dollar
premium to make budgeting even easier
and what you're going to do it's not I'm
handling it or you're handling it we're
going to look at this together and craft
a plan to help us create this future
both financially and for our family